fomo is the worst isn't it mark i don't  drink lattes no it's a it's an acronym  fear of missing out fomo fear of missing  out well i guess it would be if i  actually experienced fear well you're  not actually scared of anything why do  you ask well i mean the fear of missing  out can happen to anyone like when our  characters nate and sully don't want to  miss out on finding magellan's hidden  treasure yeah but that is five billion  dollars worth of fomo i'd fomo about  that too i mean what if you didn't  reserve tickets to see uncharted in the  theaters when they become available okay  now i see where this is going uncharted  tickets are available now so if  audiences get their tickets no more  phone no more fomo get your tickets on  fandango now  [Music]  you